when New Yorkers are outrage that nearly
are of those migrants charged in that
assault on New York's finest were
released without any bail you know
critics are blaming Manhattan district
attorney Alvin brag directly his office
did not request bail in the case he says
that case is ongoing to identify all the
asants here's his fellow Democrat New
York Governor Kathy hokel on that
certainly an assault on a police officer
is bail eligible there are over 100
crimes that are also can lead to Deep
portation and so that is also something
I want to have a conversation with uh
the district attorney about his his
options here so free to hit officers New
York Republican city councilman Vicky
Paladino joins us councilwoman so you
got some illegal immigrants allegedly
pummeling New York's finest and baale
reform rewards them by springing them
what is going on in this
country well once again no surprise from
aan brg uh true to form you know he'll
uh arrest women these two uh people for
uh uh antiva or not having false
vaccination cards but yet this scene
here that you see right now on the
screen had these guys brought them in
and released them this has become a joke
our poor police officers who were uh
taken down a notch again this week with
586 now are assaulted uh in the middle
of Time Square I mean what is going on
here what more proof does Alvin brag
need other than the kicking and the
beating that we're seeing here and these
people right here we have their pictures
we know exactly who they are they were
brought in and yet they were released
this is an absolute joke Alvin Bragg is
a joke Alvin brag should not hold the
office that he presently holds you know
he says the investigation is ongoing uh
and that sort of thing thing you know
what should he have done investigation
ongoing that's a ridiculous statement to
even make these guys are gone who are
you investigating what are you going to
do they don't live here anymore okay
there's no known address there's no
known name there's no known anything you
know whenever we ask to know uh their
IDs or where they live it's an invasion
of their privacy so that's a joke in
itself okay an ongoing investigation
what do you going to investigate if
they're not even here anymore you
mentioned 586 uh and you have a bill in
the city council for police officers to
you know identify who is illegal and
these ille illegal migrants what's going
on in the city council uh I mean where's
the the passing of the laws or the
enforcing of of laws in the city well
what's going on in the city council is
very clear uh they hate our cops we have
a progressive caucus who absolutely has
one agenda and that agenda is to
administratively defund our police so I
call it strategic misery and I also have
another name for it and it's called Uh
uh administrative defunding what we
watched happen here on Tuesday at that
special hearing that was held was
another assault on our cops to hold them
back from doing their job why do you
think they're doing this I mean is is it
a left-wing Progressive thing what's
left wing progressives yes it's the
leftwing progressives in our in our city
council that is literally pushing this
agenda about we don't need the cops we
don't need the cops to be doing this
under the guise of a lack of
transparency I want to get this in Eric
you know I have le I'm introducing
legislation right now uh it's in the uh
very early stages uh they want
transparency well you know what so do we
and uh you know there's been a lot of
debate as to whether or not the illegal
migrants in this city are causing an
increasing crime that we're seeing so my
legislative solution is to require the
NYPD to
record uh immigration status from any
person who is arrested right then and
there so we could actually know how many
of these migrants illegal immigrants are
committing these heinous crimes now
between shoplifting beating up our cops
you know there used to be a time several
decades ago where you got life
imprisonment if you killed a cop or if
you assaulted a cop the way they're
doing right now now also let's be let's
look at it this way if they know that
they are getting away with this now we
just open the door to a whole bunch of
illegals to do whatever they want war on
our cops war on our city because there
are zero
consequences and once again we're
dealing with this New York city
councilman Vicky Paladino has that bill
uh Before I Let You Go what are the
chances of the progressives in in the
council approving that you know they're
gonna they're gonna take one look at
that and do what they did with Thomas
Jefferson kick it right out I just gonna
say out it goes out done this is like we
are operating in a lawless City we are
operating with Council that really does
really has it out for our cops in plain
English they got it out for our cops all
right they removed the stature of Thomas
Jefferson from the city counil that was
disgusting that that stood there for uh
150 years or something uh city
councilwoman Vicky Paladino will keep
track of that bill and the migrant crime
crisis thank you thank you Eric for
having me on I appreciate it enjoy hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else